we have eight weeks of boot camp ahead
of us batsmen let us prepare not working
out at all
masking tape it is no friend to chilled
aluminum velcro color-coded efficient
environmentally friendly who's he
talking to
why's he dressed like a registered sex
offender can we focus for a moment
ladies please we need to talk about next
month's meal plan obviously everyone
hated the ceviche and I read the
suggestion box yeah it's on I'm gonna
stop you right there I see through this
week act you may have fooled Colossus
with this nice guy [ __ ] but not me don't
be me
Birkhoff NCW no no no no let her go let
her go it's okay she has a right to be
skeptical look at me I'm an easy target
you know historically mischief has been
my mistress so I understand but I'd like
to think that you guys have really
rubbed off I like to think that I've
rubbed off around you too
lot and for the first time in a long
while I like me I accept your apology I
never apologized I was talking to your
heart see you're not lost cause your
thoughts I'm proud you're everything I
knew you can be thank you Colossus just
trying to be the world's best x-man
sorry next person hmm something wrong
with the soap it's fine I just filled it
give it a few more pumps there now
excuse me it's dust funny season and I'm
watching Labatt's hey everybody it's
Charlie the Deadpool blu-ray is coming
out soon so they're dropping all kinds
of deleted scenes and bonus features so
let's break it down I know I'm doing
that infinity war blu-ray giveaway but
I'll do Deadpool blu-ray for this so all
you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video note to self never let Deadpool be
your roommate cook your meals or let him
use any of your soap dispensers the
funny thing about this is all the mock
sincerity in the deeply deeply
disgusting joke that they lay in and
they even cut this scene down there's an
even longer version of this on the
blu-ray with an even grosser part of the
scene that they cut out this whole scene
is happening after Deadpool has accepted
colossus a--'s offer to become an x-man
so there's a big montage during the
movie where you just see a bunch of
funny moments with him wheeling around
the x-mansion pretending like he's
trying to become an x-man we open on
Colossus doing boot camp exercises on
the lawn it's just funny watching him
doing exercises with his powers
activated but the thing about this is
that he actually doesn't need to
activate his powers when he's working
out in order to get stronger his metal
exoskeleton doesn't work like that like
he could just work out like a normal
person his skin just exudes the mettle
whenever he activates his powers so if
his muscles naturally get bigger like
you would when you workout then the
metal that forms around his body would
grow proportionately with that but the
thing about the way they do this movie
is it one it looks kind of funny in this
moment in two they've done all of
Colossus scenes with his powers
activated so at this point it would just
be really weird to see the human who
does
the voice for this character and there's
actually two different people that
perform the Colossus character there's
the person that does the mocap he's like
this giant huge person then there's the
actor that does the voice usually when
you see articles that say that Colossus
from Deadpool says this er that they're
quoting the actor that does the voice
he's viewed as the main actor they did
the same thing with juggernaut except it
was Ryan Reynolds himself that did the
voice for juggernaut so when Yuri
watched the movie listen to his lines
and see if you can detect Ryan Reynolds
in there but he's pretty good at
changing his voice and they processed it
a little bit to give it that boom
equality for someone so big Deadpool
gets really anal retentive about the way
they're organizing the fridge so he
opens it up and you see a bunch of
containers with x-men's names on it
so this is Yukio over on the right
that's the one that he grabs and rips
the label off of but you also see when
Mark Colossus and one Mark Charles
so Professor Xavier has some of his
lunch stored in there don't steal his
food or he'll have you thinking that
you're a 13 year old girl and the other
female x-men braiding your hair Logan my
tolerance you're smoking in the mansion
notwithstanding continued smoking that
in here and you'll spend the rest of
your days under the belief that you're a
six year old girl I'd have Jean braid
your hair welcome back Deadpool's OCD
solution to this problem because there
are a ton of x-men living there is to
use velcro labels and you see a whole
bunch of them one of them is Professor
X's labeled wheels in red there's Yukio
Beiste colossus and negasonic who
they're just abbreviating is n TW and
Colossus also calls her that later in
the clip too but remember there was let
other scene that made it into the movie
where they opened the door and you see
all the Dark Phoenix x-men they're gonna
be in that movie behind they're just
trying to be really quiet so the
Deadpool doesn't notice them to think
about that is that they also have a
bonus feature with a bunch of dirty
versions of that scene that they shot
and they shot it in two different
locations because they weren't filming
Dark Phoenix in the same place that they
were filming Deadpool 2 so they had to
use a green screen and just composite
those two parts so all the x-men stuff
that's happening is happening on a
completely different set in a different
location from where they're filming this
Deadpool stuff his rep
about the suggestion box makes it sound
like while he's been training to be an
x-men he's been cooking them meals on a
regular basis Deadpool is actually a
pretty decent cook in the comics usually
you just see him cooking pancakes or
chimichangas or tacos or something like
that but then as they start quipping
back and forth you actually noticed that
Yukio smug says I'm with her with an
arrow pointing at negasonic most of you
probably knew that they were a couple in
the film but a lot of negasonic scenes
got cut out that added some context to
that just because they said they slowed
the movie down so there was like a whole
bunch of other stuff that happened in
the x-mansion that just didn't make it
into the movie there's a couple moments
where like Yukio will hold it up really
close to her face like they were very
obvious with this they wanted to let you
know that they were together and
negasonic also has the same mug with the
arrow pointing in the opposite direction
most visual gags and Deadpool are pretty
obvious but every once in a while
there's like a subtle one in the
background the way they pull off this
next joke too is a little bit of both
like it's probably one of the dirtier
jokes that they've included in the
movies he makes a reference to mischief
being his mistress he's mostly talking
about the crazier girlfriends that he's
had in the comics particularly copycat
who is Vanessa who we do have during
this movie even though this version
isn't a mutant like she is in the comics
and she's way less crazy comic-book
copycat is legit nuts like especially
the early versions of the character
wrote her just completely off the
deep-end crazy there's this whole big
thing about Deadpool faking it you're
not really trying to be an x-men and
then they really drop it on you where
he's like I like to think that you've
rubbed off on me yet I have also rubbed
off around you then I love the way that
he just pauses for a beat turns and
looks at Colossus and says a lot I like
to think that I've rubbed off around you
- everybody's playing it cool except for
negasonic the reaction on her face is
priceless like she's actually thinking
about that like wait a minute has he
actually been rubbing off all over the
place around the x-mansion what's going
on this is the grossest thing ever
then without missing a beat Colossus is
pumping on the soap dispenser notice
what's in it he says I can't get it to
work then Deadpool very casually says
keep trying
I just filled it and they actually added
some sound effects like he squirts a
little bit out this is where they cut
the dirtier part of the scene out so
there's an additional part of this where
you actually see
Poole quote-unquote filling the soap
dispenser so it's super funny and super
gross at the same time and you
understand why they cut it out of the
film a little bit because of that even
though the movie is a pretty hard R that
was a bit gratuitous in this scene in
general just kind of slowed the film
down so even though it's really funny it
just didn't fit with the entire film
they just wanted to move past this
x-mansion scene so they could get into
the action of the film because the movie
starts off great but then it sort of
grinds to a halt a little bit during all
this expansion stuff until they decide
to finally go after a fire fist but
right now the movie is dropping on
digital tomorrow so you'll actually be
able to get a lot of these bonus scenes
I'll do videos for as many as I can
leave all your requests in the comments
below if you happen to be a Dragon Ball
fan there was also some new stuff that
dropped for the Dragon Ball super movie
so there's a video for that coming up
soon - but click here for all those
infinity war deleted scenes and click
here for brand new Avengers 4 thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you